quello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo io son of a vj ed oggi
siamo sul no time to explain parimenti
ragazzino detto non talento explain
sarebbe un gioco che ho già fatto secoli
fa però giocare avevo giocato alla demo
adesso che è uscito su steam il gioco
ufficiale volevo provare a giocare altro
che un figo della madonna stizza
praticamente è un gioco simile al super
meat boy per la mia gioia è praticamente
la trama sarebbe che un giorno c'è un
tizio figo molto figo era esattamente
questo che stavo per spiegare brevemente
arrivato sto tizio che dovrebbe essere
meta al futuro che ha sfondato il muro
letteralmente per dirmi che lui dal
futuro e non c'è tempo per spiegare
ok vedo che si sta divertendo che il
granchio né bell'uomo ascolta zio tu che
sei mete al futuro ma ce l'ha però la
gnocca tanta e fammi capire se si può
andare va bene che ore sono ragazzi che
ore sono sono entrato in un negozio di
orologi credo e non lo so ancora qua che
cosa ci faccio dunque non ho capito sta
cosa
[Musica]
ok ho capito è sceso tizio che continua
a essere attaccato alla casa sto granchè
ragazzi è tutto così sto gioco andrò
avanti anno beh è contento almeno
ragazzi prima di continuare devo farvi
vedere che cosa è realmente cos'è i big
money facendi mo nei perché ci sono i
money non sono morto perché io no fermi
cioè io posso posso ballare come un
idiota quando voglio amo questo gioco
scavalcare gli ostacoli e nel mentre
ballare come un rincoglionito fantastico
in russia sì non sanguinare tanto
tranquillo arrivo sono un figo ragazzi
sono vestite come boris di madre russia
dove amy hevad khan
datemi vodka da bere io boris dove il
mio me stesso tanto sono sempre più figo
o mio dio non me la ricordavo starhawk
nova seriamente vado spalare la no vabbè
fantastico no time face lane
vabbè mi mancava dalla schermata di
avvio così [ __ ] c'era un bossi metal
slug ragazzi che era identico a questo
post con uguale è fantastico ovviamente
devo scacciarli la roba
sarà pilotare l'astronave tipo così a
buffalo amico mio tu puoi provare
qualsiasi mossa contro di me ma
ricordati che io so fare questo è
assurdo chiami le palle perché io ballo
ragazzi con becco il fatto che ballo
nessuno può colpirmi è quasi nessuno
vaffan cuore dai dai dai dai dai che
così morto vai già fatta no non mi ha
presa mi chiamano male penso mi
schiacciasse di brutto perfetto che sto
o dio no lurido granchio di merda non
puoi sconfiggere mio ballo io ballo
cos'è o no ma sono morto quando quando
voglio così tanto sera sembra che io
stia avendo una diarrea pazzesca che
roba è bellissimo perché ballo con un
[ __ ] volo non so quanto ci ha messo
a far uscire chiama dovevano farlo
uscire prima perché non c'è e la vita
sto gioco fantastico ha chiesto ai
ragazzi di granchi affumicato per tutti
oggi cucina fa vi è morto nostro morto
io [ __ ] vacca reyes i granchi e la
piastra by felice è una specialità ed è
morto io so cosa sta facendo è in me
stesso di un tempo guarda come ballo
sono un figo è 6
lo farò io lo farò te lo prometto
[Musica]
i ragazzi sono esageratamente un film
cosa ti stai facendo le pippe ragazzi
devo salvare il futuro abbiamo capito
questa cosa molto semplice andiamo a
salvare il futuro ragazzi perché il
nostro compito salvaguardare la
l'umanità dai granchi e dai balli brutti
devo andare avanti posso uscire di qua
questa è casa è sempre casa mia si può
sapere perché dovunque io vada c'è
sempre un cazzo di squalo granchio
gigante che mi mangia avere un debole
per le creature di mare ragazzi non
socio questo dubbio è roba veramente
vabbè ma io ballo fotte sega ragazze di
tutto il mondo avete mai visto uno
sguardo che fulmina pd questo a chi è a
ragazzi e nero breve ma perché io posso
mai così perfetto che hai rotto il cazzo
zio fatelo dire no ma chi kayoko della
madonna che sono ragazze il cappello con
la elle proprio sanno che mi chiamo
lorenzo come fanno a saperlo ma vaffan
cuore ho fatto così a caso i bei ragazzi
non ancora capito basta avere orgasmi
stronzo non ho ancora capito il senso
visto io vengo mangiato dalle creature
giganti a caso cioè spiegatemi quale
sarebbe il punto ce la posso fare rega
perfetto no no e stava diventando
alquanto difficile vai vai vai vai vai
vai vai vai perfetto perfetto ecco lo
siamo
no madonna che idiota
giochiamo a carte ragazzi se vi va
spiegatemi come ho fatto a crepare alla
fine ci è impossibile
oddio mio santo benedetto si perfetto
che io ho cambiato armare che non è
bellissima questa la d'oro e tra l'altro
a ragazzi ho cambiato anche stile di
ballo fantastico come posso fatta
cambiare arma così ma c'è un tasto
complimenti per la mira zio
dove lanciarmi e sparate perfetto
madonna che pro e pro della sembra una
foca quando salto così ragazzi una foca
molto idiota però tanto mi stanno
paparazzano devo capire perché è la
privacy lo ritrae cazzo niente ragazzi
con simona paparazzarli come se non ci
fosse un domani non ho capito perché
ok piano piano bello complimenti per il
salto zio perfetto mica ci ho messo
vent'anni ma ci sono riuscito e carino
quando grazie a dio esiste la gravità mi
sono salvati una maniera che se ci prova
al 3 miliardi di volte non ci riesco
perfetto no vi sembrerà strano ragazzi
ma la destra alla sinistra ancora le
distingue amica mezz'ora che abbiano no
bel mitschek e testato da grazie a dio
ciò il casco ragazzi il salto mentre
ballo è una figata bello dove vado lì
sopra qui perfetto grande che orgoglio
l'orgoglio delle foche 6 ma io riesco
arrivano al traguardo così cosa ho fatto
di chiaia mi sono stata tutto il livello
a caso non pensavo funzionasse giorno
bellissimo e un bug e assurdo ragazzi
non ho idea di come abbia fatto a
trovarlo ma è una figata
se forse come in super meat boy che non
ci fossero i checkpoint sarebbe una
tragedia sto gioco
ascolta zio devi andare piano piano
bravissimo un bravissimo perfetto come
quando hai a scuola lento tanto la
faccio io la giustifica sei tranquillo
dai costò ballo maledizione vai bravo
zio la forza del qualcuno c'è shaq era
bravissimo mi6 rompendo i [ __ ] zio
ti basta questo credimi ringrazia che
non ti faccio di peggio dove sta andando
ragazzi se volete farmi un regalo di
compleanno ste cose regalatemi
quest'arma vi prego è bellissima magari
le spine no ok ok piano piano a
maledizione piano bravo zio bravo delle
noi abbiamo capito ancora ma basta una
donna modifica ammazzo
ma la moto ammazzo io no che figo devo
passare in mezzo alla all'aria all'acqua
sospesa nell'aria bellissimo dai dai dai
dai
assaggiate il mio culo low ride punte
bastardi ce l'ho fatta
oddio oh mio dio ho sudato freddo vi
giuro
figlio di [ __ ] cioè una roba no ma
chi cazzo
oddio come lo schivato ma basta replay
[Musica]
ragazzi come ho fatto a schivarlo così
non lo so ragazzi ci siamo contro il suo
squalo di merda finalmente ma insomma ma
perché la [ __ ] [ __ ] non è lui che mi
ammazzo solo io mi ammazzo da solo nel
normale sta roba ma che schifo
non riesco a ucciderlo lega impossibile
ma porca mer ottana [ __ ] bastarda ma
perché ti sposti cazzo madonna madonna
gli schiaffi in bocca gli schiaffi
ragazzi non ce la posso fare
doveva le casse cosa fa a il cag ato zio
era tua madre quella che esplosa prima
che ho detto che super meat boy e più
semplici stavo scherzando
ok non prendertela male al piano piano
piano piano prima che crepi piano per
l'amor di dio
la fai a morire normalmente come un box
normale se dio ci ho fatto
no chi cazzo sei tu che sei piu brutto o
dio santo ma cos'è sono morto non sono
anche come sono morto lega non sono
anche come sono morto dio santo no
[Musica]
[ __ ] timori se il pesce allora
fratello se la persona più bella che io
abbia mai visto fatelo direi il tuo
fascino non cagarmi il cazzo vai laver
crombie non da meno è morta ecco è
andato the bear crono sta sabotando
bombe perfetto è finito di fare il
cazzone o devi tornare deve tornare alla
ti ammazzo di nuovo timori del fratello
è morto né morto né morto cos'è o mio
dio
ancora no no bastardi la tua sorella
fuori succhiarmi non tu [ __ ] dai
ma preso non ha fatto due sono
[Applauso]
bellissima che cosa è stata colonna
sonora degna di un oscar
non so ma è una merda il gioco è una
roba siamo in una navicella spaziale
regala fatemi capire ma qui la trama
c'è una trama sto gioco continuiamo così
a vita non lo so ragazzi mica roba che
sappiamo è che non c'è tempo per
spiegare ma era rivolto a sto punto
nella demo non mi ricordo più
non lo so probabilmente le gare o meno
incassatori adesso questo sicuro novak e
figo mi risucchia sta cosa tipo come tua
sorella sempre a promuovere fetto piano
piano piano su perfetto e la madonna 6
calmo che cazzo successo sembra un
casino claustrofobico sto livello reja
non so perché mi che ha tanta roba
tanta roba tanta merda è lo sapevo che
la madre brutta perfetto ok già fatta ce
l'ho fatta si è la madonna che che pro
che pro fantasy posso ballare mentre
mentre mi distrutti a bellissima si ma
stai calmo che ti arriva un manrovescio
zio devi stare molto no no giù giù
perfetto dal gioco ragazzi è strano
perché insopportabile solo in alcuni
punti tipo questo come i giovani giovedì
bravissimo sono fatta ragazzi se muoio
adesso non ce la farò mai più ve lo dico
fuck yeah fa chi è che io vinca che io
perda le cuffie e muoiono non c'è verso
dispiace caro scusate non faccio più per
ogni mi piace che mettete al video
ragazzi una colletta per dei pantaloni
nuovi è un nuovo taglio di capelli a
quello che quello serve zio fatto lo
dire bravo bravo bravo bravo bravo la
perfetta
le giostre che figo non siamo le giostre
zio e ancora sto cazzo di granchi oddio
non che figo
mi devi al raggio fantastico non
scassare coso fratello silos cassarà il
caso perfetto fatto che è brutto che mi
devi al raggio mio dio mi sento
impotente sardo di morire sì ma ragazzi
io sto fermo così a sto punto il cazzo
stai stavo scherzando quindi dopo un tot
si butta giù e mi ammazza fantastico
fermi un attimo che ci riprovo crepa ma
[ __ ] ancora come faccio a schivarlo
impossibile fuori dai ti prego non è
morto [ __ ] né morto kay ok ok
adesso suo bravo non morire bravo bravo
applausi non è morto ragazzi non è morto
e mi fa veramente strano sta cosa mamma
mia che che sudata dai forza no mi è
caduto in testa tuo padre cazzo possa
farcela star di fuori money money money
money money money money non muore non
muore non muore
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye di morire
dei morire di morire morire non muore
ancora non muore ancora non muore ancora
o dio santo ti ringrazio mio finito di
mico finito chi cazzo è quello ragazzi
quanto siete swag cosa fa no mi ha preso
e appreso a scusa se non volevo che ci
siamo andati a sbattere per colpa mia da
qualche parte nell'anno 2000 hicks ma
[ __ ] però c'è stato verso cos'è
contro i coccodrilli pavé ragazzi il
primo episodio concludo quater che sta
diventando tutto troppo
ataf ha quindi ragazzi con curve
episodio su mi piace per il fatto che
siamo tornati nel futuro cosa che non
avrei pensato neanche io però madonna
quindi ragazzi spero che ognuno vi sia
piaciuto è come se vi è piaciuta
certamente mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come nei video trattando
estinzione prestiti stiratrici mi davano
passionalità belle ragazze